au détour d'une allée à Las Vegas sur
des trucs de fou regardez-moi cet écran
il est énorme alors en fait c'est un
affichage qui leur permet de faire de la
publicité vous savez probablement qu'à
Las Vegas ils adorent mettre de la pub
de partout et ils le font ici sous une
espèce d'énormes Géode alors pour
réussir cette prouesse technologique a
priori ça pourrait être des dalles mini
LED c'est des triangles en fait qui sont
posés tous les côtés et ce qui permet
d'avoir ce côté incurvé alors on le voit
on va avoir de la pub pour des
spectacles pour de la nourriture on a
même une mappemonde avec la terre qui
donne beaucoup de profondeur un très
gros smiley bref ça c'est marrant je
voulais partager avec vous si on se
baladant dans une allée comme ça et les
trucs très drôles et d'ailleurs si un
jour vous avez l'occaz venez faire un
tour à Vegas pour voir ce monde qui est
juste dingo